- Depuis lundi, ces ambulanciers
paramédicaux font plus
qu'amener les patients
aux portes de l'urgence.
Ils enfilent désormais
l'équipement de protection
des infirmières pour faire
une partie de leur travail.
CÉDRIC RIVIÈRE, technicien
ambulancier paramédical
- C'est pour ça qu'on est là.
C'est pour prêter main forte
aux infirmières. On le sait que
les infirmières sont épuisées.
Je vais juste vous installer
le brassard pour la pression.
- Ces ambulanciers paramédicaux
prennent les signes vitaux,
mesurent la glycémie
ou installent l'oxygène.
Un travail essentiel,
des tâches en moins pour
les employés de l'urgence.
- Ça donne des bras de plus.
Et là, on aide autant
les infirmières que les préposés
parce que tout ce qui est
habillement, tout ce qui est
jaquette, c'est souvent
la préposée qui le fait.
Donc, on vient aider
plusieurs sphères de l'urgence.
- Par contre, où est-ce que je
vais avoir besoin de ton aide...
- Une quinzaine de paramédicaux
ont suivi la formation pour
travailler à l'urgence.
- Selon la couleur de notre
patient, si notre patient,
il est vert ou il est jaune...
- Une idée du CISSS
de Montérégie-Centre pour
éliminer le fameux temps
supplémentaire obligatoire.
APRIL FEQUET, cheffe urgence,
Hôpital du Haut-Richelieu
- Nous, dans notre urgence,
le TSO, c'est pas une option.
Il n'y a pas de TSO dans
notre urgence. Ce n'est pas
notre façon de procéder. Nous,
on a décidé de se réorganiser.
- Les paramédics travailleront
donc avec les infirmières
à l'urgence, au moins
jusqu'au mois de décembre.
- Au niveau des médecins aussi,
ils ont tout réorganisé
certaines tâches pour justement
aussi enlever la charge
de travail des infirmières.
Chacun a vraiment donné
leur 200 % pour dire : qu'est-ce
qu'on faire justement peut
réduire la surcharge de travail?
- Je vais prendre ta température
aussi. Si tu es capable
de baisser ton masque...
- Tous ces paramédics souhaitent
ainsi prouver qu'ils peuvent
élargir leur rôle dans
le réseau de la santé.
- On est polyvalents,
et puis, on veut le démontrer
qu'on est polyvalents.
- Deux autres établissements
de la région de Montréal
vont aussi faire appel
à des ambulanciers paramédicaux
pour appuyer les infirmières
des urgences, épuisées
par 18 mois de pandémie.
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, M